une humaine de travailler sans salaire
ouais il mal quand l'amour de la terre
devient un enfer pression de la grande
distribution
intempéries marché mondialisé un
agriculteur se suicident tous les deux
jours
deux semaines
le malaise s'est instauré peu à peu dans
la france d'après guerre
le secteur agricole est en pleine
mutation l'exode rural se poursuit les
enfants d'agriculteurs rêve de la ville
j'aurais travaillé à jiji vous ne voulez
pas travailler la terre comme votre père
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas je
passais rentable pour ceux qui restent
il faut vivre avec son temps
la mécanisation s'accélère les
agriculteurs doivent s'endetter pour
s'équiper la machine remplace les hommes
le marché est désormais européen il faut
alors produire davantage
difficile pour les petits producteurs de
passer à une grande échelle
qu'est ce que je veux dire les gars on
défend l'agriculture d'un type
capitaliste et nous on nous laisse
finalement à mourir en dehors des
exploitations de grande taille la vie
d'agriculteur reste modeste les recettes
vont aux créanciers et des loisirs
passent à la trappe
un prix moyen âge payer l'hôtel ou dans
les mmo resterons jamais alors même pas
le cinéma est ce qu'il y avait quelque
chose je vous dirais qu'il ya 12 heures
et je prêtais la situation devient
critique dans les années 90 la
concurrence européen et mondial renforce
la paupérisation des paysans français
moi je
je vends mon temps je tenais le beurre
mais j'arrête l'agriculture j'arrête de
métier d'agriculteur ça marche plus le
malaise est profond à cette période au
début des années 90 la télé se fait
l'écho de cas de suicides d'agriculteurs
des dizaines de reportages chaque année
j'ai enlevé aux pouvoirs publics genval
europe j'en veux j'en veux à tous nos
dirigeants qui ne comprennent pas la
situation actuelle de l'agriculture
l'europe l'état attribue des subventions
aux agriculteurs mais les exploitants
dénonce l' asphyxie que fait subir la
grande distribution en quête de prix
toujours plus bas
on veut que les centrales d'achat paix
le produit à son juste prix
ils sont en train de nous mettre de nous
mettre à genoux ça ne sert à rien de
donner des subventions d'un côté et
d'affamer les agriculteurs de l'autre on
n'en peut plus d'un demi siècle la
france paysanne a changé de visage plus
compétitive plus mécanisés moins
prégnante dans l'économie du pays
en 1955 la france comptait plus de 2
millions d'exploitations agricoles en 60
ans leur nombre a été divisé par cinq
[Musique]